la plupart des pays on vient de le voir
dans le monde qui misent donc sur la
vaccination pour sortir de la crise
sanitaire quitte à isoler ou à
stigmatiser de plus en plus les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés on va
en parler justement ce matin avec pierre
alexandre faire les tic notre
journaliste web à rt france
[Musique]
bonjour un pierre alexandre
vous avez donc écrit longuement sur ce
sujet le sujet des sanctions dans cette
crise sanitaire est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus
oui alors effectivement de paris à
melbourne les mesures contre les non
vaccinés s'accumulent depuis et
plusieurs mois certains pays ont
purement et simplement mis en place des
obligations vaccinales sanctionner très
classiquement d'amande ou de suspension
de salaire pour les non vaccinés mais
dans d'autres cas la créativité des
pouvoirs publics est assez surprenante
et quels sont selon vous les mesures les
plus originales prises contre les non
vaccinés et pira exemple
et bien la palme revient selon moi à la
province pakistanaise du pendjab où
depuis juin dernier les non-vaccinés un
voile les cartes sim de leur téléphone
bloqué dans cette mesure peut paraître
risible mais elle en fait une grande
importance dans ce pays où une immense
majorité de la population a accès à
internet uniquement via les téléphones
portables on peut aussi citer le cas de
l'indonésie où certains n'ont vacciné se
voir refuser la délivrance de leur
permis de conduire ou couper les aides
sociales ou ne reçoivent plus de
courriers nécessaires au démarrage d'une
activité professionnelle
ces mesures ont d'ailleurs pu donner
lieu à des situations particulièrement
problématique comme cette jeune femme de
19 ans qui a vu sa plainte pour viol
refusé car elle ne disposait pas du
certificat vaccinale indispensable pour
entrer dans le poste de police
et de telles mesures existent tels
également en europe
et bien même si elles sont plus
ordinaire des mesures inédites contre
les non vaccinés fleurissent également
sur notre continent l'autriche par
exemple a été le premier pays au monde à
imposer en novembre un confinement
nationale pour les seulement vaccinés
chez leurs voisins allemands les
salaires des personnes non vaccinées
placés en quarantaine ne sont plus pris
en charge depuis le 1er novembre et les
autorités berlinoises avait même
autorisé leur guise et les organisateurs
pardon des marchés de noël à introduire
des règles strictes pour les personnes
souhaitant s'y rendre sur ces temps de
tel en dehors de la sphère publique
eh bien oui aux etats-unis par exemple
de nombreux grands employeurs tels que
google facebook ou united airlines ont
imposé la vaccination contre le coc u19
alors salariés outre les licenciements
les incitations à la vaccination peuvent
prendre d'autres formes la compagnie
aérienne delta airlines a ainsi annoncé
en août qu'elle augmenterait les primes
d'assurance de 200 dollars par mois pour
ses employés qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés plus grave encore un groupe de
santé du colorado a retiré les personnes
non vaccinées des listes de
transplantation d'organes pour cause de
non conformité
on reste maintenant à savoir si ces
mesures auront un réel effet incitatif
sur la minorité d'individus qui ressort
d'être vaccinés ou si elles ne sont que
renforcer leur roger quel qu'en soit le
motif merci beaucoup pierre alexandre
pour tout c'est précis